consiste en contener los estallidos de
proyectos que manipulando la genuina
irritación ciudadana avanzan con
acciones demagógicas y despóticas y no
podemos dar cabida a discursos que
busquen con ofertas engañosas sacrificar
la sagrada libertad
el mundo
requiere más que nunca templanza diálogo
y moderación
vivimos tiempos que demandan compromisos
políticos concretos y no actitudes
genéricas más aún en los años
posteriores a la pandemia que se
proyectan difíciles y requerirán
reformas complejas que deben blindarse
de falsas promesas
en América Latina siendo una de las
regiones más afectadas por la coyuntura
debemos estar predispuestos a adoptar
posiciones de principio que se alineen
con la preocupación por la plena
vigencia de los derechos humanos y el
autogobierno colectivo
sin embargo estas posturas tienen que
inscribirse en un plano amplio de
cooperación en el que los países mejor
posicionados sean conscientes del
desequilibrio que caracteriza al planeta
en todos sus ámbitos
debemos brindar estabilidad al mundo con
una voz común no podemos correr la vista
de lo que sucede en otros territorios y
dejar a su suerte a naciones hermanas
por ello
Paraguay es un país solidario que
mantiene coherencia con sus principios
hemos apoyado siempre al hermano pueblo
venezolano y a su lucha por la
democracia por eso Paraguay estará
liderando en el consejo de Derechos
Humanos junto con otros países una
resolución que permitirá seguir
investigando a profundidad la violación
de los Derechos Humanos en Venezuela
necesitamos reconstruir una conciencia
moral sobre la vigencia de los derechos
humanos y la democracia
Los instrumentos jurídicos y las
instituciones que hemos creado para
protegerlos tienen un valor innegable
sin embargo el elemento fundamental para
custodiar a las personas sigue siendo
consolidar una Concepción respecto al
valor superior de su dignidad
indio la habilidad y autonomía
la difícil coyuntura actual nos demanda
abordar los problemas mundiales de forma
conjunta sin exclusiones por ello mi
país reitera enfáticamente el apoyo a la
solicitud de la República de China
Taiwán para ser parte integral de
sistema de las Naciones Unidas
estamos convencidos del valioso aporte
que implica su participación en el
sistema multilateral
aprovecho el momento
para expresar mi solidaridad por el
terremoto que acaba de afectar al pueblo
taiwanés y los diferentes episodios
vividos en México en República
Dominicana y en Puerto Rico
el Paraguay se adhiere a la inmensa
mayoría de países que abogan por la paz
el Imperio del derecho internacional y
la prevalencia de la diplomacia nos
preocupa la situación en Ucrania y las
consecuencias humanitarias y económicas
del conflicto
hacemos un llamado enérgico al cese de
las hostilidades y a la reanudación de
las negociaciones es fundamental que
nuestra organización y la comunidad
internacional en general participen
intensamente en este proceso
de cara este escenario es inevitable
señalar el escrutinio sobre el papel que
le corresponde al consejo de seguridad
en el en el delicado contexto
internacional
e imperioso repensar su funcionamiento
para orientarlo hacia un desempeño
efectivo así como fortalecer el rol de
la asamblea general como espacio de
canalización de la palabra de todos los
estados
otro tema que nos convoca en términos de
cooperación es la salud del sistema
financiero internacional
no es posible seguir hablando de
iniciativas globales para erradicar la
pobreza y promover el desarrollo
sostenible cuando nuestras economías se
ven contaminadas por la diseminación de
ganancias provenientes de las
actividades ilícitas
recientemente Paraguay recibió noticias
satisfactorias del grupo de acción
financiera de latinoamérica Al haber
superado su evaluación gracias al
trabajo conjunto de modernización de
nuestra estructura institucional para el
combate alabado de dinero y el
financiamiento del terrorismo somos un
país comprometido con la cooperación y
entendemos la importancia de adoptar
medidas preventivas y sancionatorias
esa es una tarea en la que ningún estado
debería estar fuera o mantener una
posición tenue el Imperio de la ley es
un objetivo global que está más allá de
las concepciones políticas y quien no lo
concibe así conspira contra la vida en
comunidad
bajo mi administración Paraguay alineó
como nunca antes los esfuerzos de las
instituciones de seguridad y las puso a
trabajar en la mayor operación de la
historia contra el crimen organizado
ese éxito se debió no solo a la labor de
Nuestra fuerza públicas sino también al
trabajo coordinado que se llevó adelante
con agencias extranjeras amidas Con
quienes comprobamos de nuevo la
importancia de unir energías Si queremos
lograr resultados contra los grupos
delictivos así también en colaboración
con agencias de inteligencia
determinamos Y alertamos el recorrido de
un avión y su tripulación señalada de
estar vinculada al terrorismo
internacional
otro escenario de cooperación es el
campo del desarrollo sostenible Paraguay
como parte del motor mundial de
generación de alimentos viene avanzando
en la transformación de su matriz
productiva la ejecución de prácticas
sostenibles en la producción agrícola y
Ganadera y el aprovechamiento de su
energía 100%
limpia y renovable
pero para que todos nuestros impulsos
realmente adquieran sentido necesitamos
que lo que los países que por sus
características tienen mayor
responsabilidad actúen En consecuencia
habitamos el mismo planeta Y tenemos la
obligación de cuidar la naturaleza y el
futuro de nuestra generación Y eso
compete en su justa medida cada estado
por eso Paraguay junto a otros países
promovió la creación de un relator
especial sobre cambio climático en el
consejo de Derechos Humanos que
contribuirá a visibilizar el verdadero
impacto que tiene esta crisis a nivel
mundial
La Apuesta por el Paraguay sigue
creciendo cada día más además de
encontrarnos entre los cinco países de
la región que lograron incrementar la
inversión extranjera directa durante la
pandemia pudimos duplicar la inversión
privada en los últimos cuatro años hace
unos meses vimos mejorada nuestra
perspectiva crediticia según la firma
muris hecho que se corresponde con la
histórica sensata y estable
administración de nuestra economía
somos parte del corredor logístico y
económico más importante de América del
Sur
paralelamente seguimos desplegando un
plan de infraestructura sin precedentes
que permite mayor conectividad y acceso
a los mercados como puede verse a pesar
de los difíciles desafíos vividos
gozamos de condiciones que nos hacen
mirar el futuro con esperanzas
finalmente
Quisiera dejar con la que la República
del Paraguay se aproxima al mundo Más
allá de las legítimas diferencias que
nos caracterizan tenemos que encontrar
caminos comunes tenemos retos comunes
que no nos pueden encontrar separados mi
país se encuentra comprometido con esta
organización y Espera que sus propósitos
sean alcanzados
como dijo el Papa Francisco
todos estamos en la misma Barca y
estamos llamados a comprometernos para
que no haya más muros que no se paren
deseo que Dios bendiga a todas nuestras
naciones Muchas gracias